okay let's talk about trigger warnings
and safe spaces the Dean at the
University of Chicago informed incoming
freshman last week that the University
will not condone safe spaces or trigger
warnings on campus here is a quote from
the letter from John Ellison the Dean of
Students saying once here you will
discover that one of the University of
Chicago's defining characteristics is
our commitment to freedom of inquiry and
expression members of our community are
encouraged to speak right listen
challenge and learn without fear of
censorship we do not support so-called
trigger warnings we do not cancel
invited speakers because their topics
might prove controversial and we do not
condone the creation of intellectual
safe spaces where individuals can
retreat from ideas and perspective at
odds with their own huge reaction online
some people saying this is great the
University of Chicago is not going to
coddle students they are not going to
shield students from what many might
perceive as bigotry or offensive comment
or whatever and then there are others
who have been critical of this letter
saying you know what they are going
above and beyond and proactively saying
you are going to be offended here I
don't agree with that critique I think
very few people in our audience are
going to agree with my view Jason
because I completely and wholeheartedly
support the content of this letter I am
against these trigger warnings I am
against these safe spaces I believe that
you are not being prepared for a life in
the real world if from ages 18 to 22 you
were protected from anything that might
be traumatic or offensive or whatever
colleges as a whole should be safe
spaces for all ideas to be explored
no actual physical violence should be
tolerated no actual bullying or shouting
down of any ideas should be tolerated
but it's not producing it's not
productive or conducive I think I just
made another newer
dictionary where their producer I expect
that to be there by tomorrow it's not
conducive nor productive if we are
trying to build leaders and people to
exist in the real world to protect them
in this way in colleges however I don't
agree with actually sending this letter
and the reason I don't agree with it is
I don't actually think that this is a
statement colleges should have to make
by default it should be assumed that
colleges are not spaces for safe spaces
or trigger warnings and I know people
might hear this and say but David
because they've become that in many ways
it's perfectly legitimate for the
University of Chicago to put together
this letter and proactively say it will
not be allowed I say wait until the
trigger warnings and safe spaces are
attempted at your school and then say
that you don't stand behind them but I
don't know that I agree with the
proactive delivery of this letter
although I 110 percent agree with its
content yeah well mmm that's a tough one
I think I believe in the trial by fire
the experience of the world and that you
actually have to go out there and
experience experience and get hardened
by society because it is a cold hard
world out there and I know that's what a
lot of people say and I don't even go
that far for me it's just if you're
going to work somewhere if you're going
to exist in the real world if you're
going to even go to the grocery store I
hear offensive racist insulting stuff
all the time I hear stuff in the real
world all the time that I recognize if
somebody had a traumatic experience in
their past related to race
discrimination related to sexual assault
etc I get how those things could be
jarring in some way but if for four
years in college you are sort of
conditioned to expect that you will be
artificially are isolated from those
realities those realities will only be
more destructive when you get out of
college and go to the real world and
that's sort of my big picture on this
yeah there's a fine line there though
because at some point it becomes assault
it's not obviously not battery but
assault is just threatening people and
you know there
of a very fine line there to be written
by these schools because they become
liable it's important for this but
that's not what the letter was about to
be clear and I agree with you anytime
but I don't want sometimes critiques of
political correctness are really just
anger by people who want to be
deliberately offensive and I don't
support that and sometimes critiques of
safe spaces and trigger warnings are
coming from people who just want to
deliberately be offensive and upset
other people and I don't support that
use of these policies or fighting back
against these policies but big picture I
think I've been clear sort of about my
view and I'm curious to hear from the
audience about this number one is the
content of the letter which I agree with
and number two it's the choice to send
this letter to freshman as they are
coming into the school before they've
even been subjected to these trigger
warnings and safe spaces that I am not
so thrilled with send me your thoughts
and we'll definitely follow up about it
Warby Parker is offering a free five day
home Tryon to give you the opportunity
to check out their glasses I personally
wear Warby Parker glasses when I'm not
wearing my contact lenses and I also
started with one of these free at home
try ons of five pairs of glasses you can
get your free home try on and support
the david pakman show at Warby Parker
trialed comm slash TDPS
I don't really like going into glasses
stores and trying on glasses while the
salesperson sort of hovers over me and I
like more than 30 seconds to actually
figure out whether I like the glasses so
with the Warby Parker home Tryon I was
able to pick five pairs that I liked put
them on in the comfort of my own home
pick the one I liked the most and then
Warby Parker put my prescription lenses
in there for me a lot of people don't
know that the eyeglass industry is
controlled by just a few big
corporations that keep prices very high
like $300 for prescription glasses high
which is just insane Warby Parker
glasses start at $95 that's what mine
cost and for every pair of glasses sold
Warby Parker distributes a pair of
glasses to someone in need
you can try five pairs and see what you
like
check out the at home trial and support
our show by going to Warby Parker comm
slash TDP s it costs nothing